en estos últimos vídeos hemos avanzado
poco a poco hacia construir nuestro
modelo de la demanda agregada y la
oferta agregada le voy a escribir por
acá el modelo con este color modelo
modelo de la oferta agregada y de la
demanda agregada en el fondo lo estamos
construyendo porque los economistas
decidieron diseñarlo para explicar de
una manera un poco más matemática cómo
funciona el ciclo económico porque se
dan estos altibajos en la producción
aunque parecería ser que con un
crecimiento de población y de tecnología
la economía siempre debería de ir hacia
arriba pero recuerda o sea todo estoy
acá es un posible modelo para explicar
las cosas y en realidad como cualquier
modelo lo tienes que tomar con un ojo
crítico tiene que tener mucho cuidado y
tienes que cuestionar cada una de sus
suposiciones o sea a lo mejor a ti no te
gusta y dices no pues quiero modificar
lo quiero hacer este cambio y entonces a
partir de ahí ya puedes encontrar otro
tipo de deducciones siempre y cuando
estén bien justificadas lo bueno de
tener uno
así es que nos permite describir
fenómenos muy complejos esto de la
economía es un fenómeno súper complejo
verdad o sea en realidad los seres
humanos somos seres con millones de
neuronas cada quien está pensando una
cosa y cada quien tiene sus preferencias
y de repente uno puede actuar en la
economía de una manera pues muy muy muy
así fuera de lo común y entonces el
modelo se cae completamente pero lo
padre del modelo es que pues todos estos
millones de neuronas y millones de
actores están resumidos en algunas
cuantas suposiciones y pues gracias a
eso podemos ver todo este fenómeno súper
complejo en términos de líneas en
términos de algunos puntos
independientes
entonces de lo que estábamos en el vídeo
pasado era en ver la oferta agregada a
largo plazo y ya habíamos dibujado una
gráfica de cómo se veía supusimos que
era que el producto interno bruto real
era constante en oferta
no importa si los precios cambiarán
entonces había algunos peros porque a lo
mejor la gente se sentía con una actitud
diferente a sí pero en el fondo la idea
es que la capacidad productiva no
depende del precio si la capacidad
productiva es algo independiente de un
numerito que dice cuánto cuestan las
cosas entonces esto ya caerá la oferta
agregada a largo plazo va entonces bueno
está aquí el oferta agregada a largo
plazo que es un cierto nivel de
producción natural pero en lo que quiero
hacer énfasis ahorita es que esto de acá
no es el máximo que puede producir la
economía en realidad el máximo tendría
que ir por otro lado déjame dibujar a
acá
una línea punteada para indicar esto
estoy acá sería el nivel máximo esté
aquí sería como un máximo teórico
ahorita pasamos a el máximo teórico
teórico y estoy acá es nada más un nivel
natural si dejarlo ponerle aquí entre
comillas natural y cuando digo natural
me refiero a que la economía usualmente
no puede estar a su nivel máximo
usualmente la economía tiene cierto
desempleo que está dado por ciertas
razones muy naturales porque la gente
necesita capacitarse más o porque de
repente hay altibajos en las ventas hay
ciertas épocas que tienen más producción
o que tienen más demanda y además pues
no sé a veces la gente tiene que salir
de un trabajo para buscar otro etcétera
no nacen hijos hay muchas razones por
las cuales la economía no puede estar a
su máximo entonces este de acá es un
nivel natural un nivel saludable de la
economía esto ya casi es un máximo
teórico pero es súper difícil de
calcular sí o sea en realidad este
máximo implicaría que todas las fábricas
estuvieran trabajando de la manera más
eficiente que se aprovechara muy bien el
terreno
que las mejores personas se les pusiera
a trabajar en las tareas en las cuales
lo hacen mejor y así bueno a todas las
personas en las tareas en las cuales lo
hace mejor que no tomen ni vacaciones ni
descanso pero eso es imposible verdad
siempre hay ciertas imperfecciones en el
sistema económico que no permiten llegar
a este máximo teórico de acá y de hecho
que hacen súper difícil calcular cuál
sería este máximo teórico van bueno
entonces estoy acá es nada más como un
nivel natural este de aquí es el máximo
así en el 5 alto todos están trabajando
lo que vamos a ver ahorita es la oferta
agregada pero ahora si a corto plazo y
está como se vería ésta también tendría
bueno tendría una gráfica de la
siguiente manera seria
lo voy a dibujar con líneas punteadas
porque así me salen mejor mis líneas
curvas algo de este estilo más o menos
va entonces lo del máximo fue importante
porque ahora si esta curva va a ir así y
se va a acercar asintóticamente a esto
de acá no puede llegar al producto
interno bruto este del nivel máximo pero
observa que está diciendo esta curva de
acá esta curva está diciendo que hay una
pendiente positiva verdad está diciendo
que digamos a mayor precio entonces la
oferta va a ser mayor pero como le
hacemos para pensar en esto para empezar
para que lo necesitamos estoy acá lo
vamos a necesitar para justificar el
ciclo económico y en el fondo que está
diciendo o sea en el fondo está diciendo
que si aumentan los precios entonces la
gente va a estar motivada a producir más
por ejemplo si estamos en este nivel
natural y aumentan tanto los precios
como para acá entonces esto se va a
desplazar a esta altura verdad entonces
ahora vamos a tener un producto interno
bruto como por acá y eso quiere decir
que aumento entonces un incremento en el
precio hace que la gente trabaje más que
las fábricas se encuentren trabajando
más tiempo de modo similar si el precio
disminuye si estamos en el nivel natural
pero bajamos el precio entonces ahora la
gente va a estar motivada a trabajar un
poco menos a lo mejor van a tomar un
poco más de vacaciones
las fábricas no van a estar abiertas
todo el día va esto es lo que quiere
decir la gráfica pero vamos a pensar
cuáles posibles explicaciones puede
haber o cuáles posibles pues teorías no
entonces déjame escribirlas por acá
básicamente son dos y la primera se le
conoce como la teoría de la percepción
incorrecta le voy a poner aquí la teoría
teoría de la percepción percepción
incorrecta
y aunque se llame de la percepción
incorrecta vas a ver que es algo muy
natural o sea que alguien caiga en una
actitud de este estilo imaginas e
imagínate que pues que de repente yo soy
una persona que tiene su fábrica de de
calcetines o de lo que sea de algo muy
específico y veo que los precios
empiezan a subir a lo mejor yo no me doy
cuenta que es un fenómeno macroeconómico
y pienso que es algo micro económico que
es algo local yo como actor individual
pues tengo la impresión de que ese
cambio de precios solo es dentro de mí
esté dentro de mi rama dentro de mi
industria y por tanto creo que mis
bienes y servicios aumentan de precio es
decir confundo este cambio
macroeconómico con un cambio micro
económico micro micro económico y por
tanto pues que voy a percibir recuerda
que todo esto es de la percepción
incorrecta o sea si va a haber un cambio
macroeconómico ok pero yo como actor
individual lo percibo como un cambio
micro económico y entonces va a entrar
en acción la ley de la oferta y de la
demanda la de nivel
microeconómico la de la oferta oferta
demanda
demanda entonces yo como como productor
puedo decir está súper padre esto los
precios aumentaron entonces yo debería
de empezar a poner mis fábricas a
trabajar más para poder producir más
calcetines que esos calcetines se vendan
a un mayor precio y entonces pueda ganar
más dinero eso es más o menos lo que
está detrás de esta teoría y bueno en
términos reales si se obtiene más dinero
pero nominalmente no porque como todo
está creciendo igual como todo el precio
aumenta entonces pues aunque ganes más s
más te va a servir para para comprar
menos o bueno para comprar lo mismo y
entonces en realidad aunque aumente es
esto para acá pues no no pues no va a
funcionar verdad ahora incluso tú puedes
querer postergar su mantenimiento o
puedes pedirle a tus empleados que se
queden más y que no tomen vacaciones
pero en el fondo sólo era una ilusión
pues el nivel de productividad y aunque
sí por el momento aumenta y va a moverse
para cada los precios están arriba luego
de todo se van a dar cuenta que en
realidad así no eran las cosas que era
una ilusión y esto va a regresar a su
nivel de productividad irregular si eso
a pasar con un individuo pero obviamente
la economía no está dirigida por un solo
individuo verdad yo que soy el dueño de
los calcetines pues es muy difícil que
bueno es imposible que yo dirija toda la
economía de modo que en realidad esto
pues realmente hace un cambio cuando
sumas lo que pasa con todos los actores
y entonces todos los actores hacen algo
por el estilo y por eso se da este tipo
de cambio y de que de que se mueve
tantito la producción luego se dan
cuenta de que no es sostenible eso y
regresa a su nivel de producción normal
esa es la primera razón la teoría de la
percepción incorrecta la segunda razón y
es la segunda que puedes leer así en
libros de texto y lo que sea se llama la
teoría de las cuotas rígidas entonces
voy a poner teoría de las cuotas
cuotas que le podemos poner las cuotas
rígidas podemos poner las cuotas rígidas
o bien le podemos poner la teoría de los
costos rígidos costos rígidos
o también podemos ponerle la teoría de
los precios rígidos si los rígidos
rígidos en la edad cualquiera cualquiera
de estos tanto las cuotas como los
costos como los precios reflejan un
mismo fenómeno sí y la idea básicamente
es que hay algunos costos o algunas
cuotas que ya están establecidas al
corto plazo recuerda que ahorita ya todo
lo estamos pensando a corto plazo si
aquí no le escrito pero esto es la
oferta agregada a corto plazo todo es a
corto plazo entonces a corto plazo puede
haber ciertos contratos ciertos
contratos que obliguen a que las cuotas
estén fijas y que no se puedan bajar o
subir también puede haber algunos costos
por los cuales ya se hicieron algunos
tratos se compraron cosas por anticipado
o más bien se pagaron después entonces
puede estar pagando se acreditó y no
puede cambiar eso porque la tasa es fija
o lo que sea entonces esto la teoría de
las cuotas rígidas básicamente dice que
hay precios que no se pueden cambiar
rápidamente hay otra forma de verlo de
hecho hay otro otro ingrediente que
colabora en este sentido
que se llama estoy acá que es el costo
de menús y le voy a poner por acá costo
de menú
menú y la idea de esto del costo de menú
es la siguiente es que pues aunque los
precios cambien y no estén en contratos
verdad y porque podamos cambiar los eso
no quiere decir que sea fácil cambiarlos
por ejemplo si en un restaurant de
repente le aumentan el precio del
jitomate de la lechuga y de la gasolina
para transportar sus cosas entonces pues
aunque le aumenten estos costos no es
fácil para restaurar modificar sus
precios frente a los clientes porque
tienen que volver a imprimir su menú eso
de ahí viene el nombre pero en realidad
hay otra situación es verdad o sea en
general pues puede ser que tú eres una
persona que tiene un cierto portafolio
que ofrece ciertos servicios pero es muy
difícil volver a cambiar sus servicios
avísale a tu gente de ventas que se va a
cambiar en los costos volverá pues
cotizar los proyectos y cosas por el
estilo entonces de eso se trata el costo
de menú pero como esta idea de que los
precios son fijos o bien de que es
difícil cambiarlos hace que la oferta
agregada a corto plazo
aumente y se vaya para acá la
explicación es la siguiente a corto
plazo no se puede cambiar el precio va
entonces qué sucede con una persona que
de repente ve que puede seguir comprando
al mismo precio pero que puede pues
digamos como que ganar más vendiendo más
cosas entonces vamos a la situación de
una persona déjame ponerla por acá y
tenemos a una una fábrica o lo que sea
que de repente sus distribuidores están
con un cierto contratos y tienen que
venderle a cierto precio que es barato
pero de repente los precios suben pues
ellos pueden vender a un mayor precio
ellos no entonces ellos aumentan su
precio y por tanto ellos están generando
mucha ganancia ahorita verdad por lo
tanto esto causa que estén motivados a
producir más para poder aprovechar esta
situación claro y eventualmente este
contrato se va a vencer pero por el
momento ellos pueden aprovechar este
momento para producir mucho para poner
las máquinas a todo lo que dan para
postergar el mantenimiento y producir
muchas unidades venderlas y tener muchas
ganancias vale esa es la idea
ahora porque digo que esto de que costos
rígidos y de qué precios rígidos de lo
mismo pues supongamos que esta es la
empresa de la empresa de acá y tenemos
una empresa que es la que le está dando
servicios no sé digamos que le vende
limonadas no le vende limones sabe y
beben de limonadas entonces es muy
difícil para cambiar el precio con ver
porque hicieron un contrato pero para
ver es muy sencillo cambiar su letrero
entonces ve puede vender más alto ese es
el fenómeno pero bueno o sea finalmente
el costo de comprar los limones debe y
es lo mismo que el precio de vender los
limones de ahí por eso digo que costos y
precios es básicamente lo mismo para
entonces estoy acá en la oferta agregada
a corto plazo y estas dos son las
posibles explicaciones para decir que la
curva va hacia arriba que tiene una
pendiente positiva